Well,
postcolonial studies is a really,
by far the most varied and eclectic of
the identity fields that were passing in
review, uh, in this, in
this portion of the, uh,
of the course. Uh, uh, eclectic
really I've necessity of course,
because of the immense of the immense
variety of the materials are covered,
but also because of a swirling issues
and controversies within postcolonial
studies or Poco as it's
affectionately known, uh, which,
um, but which kind of pose
a number of questions, um,
from the side that, uh, that, that,
that keep things lively
to say the least. We, um,
are taking up only one strand,
a developmental strand in
postcolonial studies today, uh, uh,
kind of a progression from the
work of sight to the work of Baba,
which is relatively easily map simply
in terms simply in terms of the,
uh, of the intellectual
agendas of each of them.
But there's a great deal else going
on. And I, and I suppose I should,
I should just mention in passing a certain
topics that we won't be discussing,
uh, at least, uh, except
possibly in passing.
And that however you might
really be interested in
considering if you do have an
interest in this field. Um, the first,
the first issue of course
is who says post colonial.
That is who says that we're
necessarily out of colonialism.
Just because the local viceroy packs up
and goes home doesn't necessarily mean
that things change all that significantly
in the so called postcolonial setting.
Uh,
and it needs to be taken into account,
seriously considered whether or not
one isn't still in colonial or colonial
studies.
Uh,
and that the moniker postcolonial
postcolonial might therefore be
inappropriately applied.
There's also,
there's also the question,
uh,
that arises in the study of
the so called Third World,
which is obviously in itself a
controversial term. You know,
it arises as that which is not
comprised as either of the great,
uh, sort of trajectories of the
superpowers during the Cold War. Uh,
there is no cold cold war,
at least allegedly no cold war any longer.
And so the question of the status,
nature and structure of the third
world is obviously wide open.
But the issue I mean to touch on in terms
of postcolonial studies is whether in
fact a crises, uh, and,
uh,
and concerns with respect to the
third world are necessarily always,
uh, to be understood in terms of
coloniality that, you know, I mean is,
is it just that,
uh,
certain parts of the globe have been
colonized that constitutes them as they
are, uh, and shapes their
identity. So Aden and in a,
in a very interesting way,
takes this up in trying to figure out
how it is that German orientalism so very
closely resembles French orientalism.
Even though the Germans had no
colonial interests in the Middle East.
Uh, they are, uh, they,
during the whole period,
early 19th century in particular,
when German orientalism is practically
indistinguishable from the French,
takes up the same concerns,
has the same interest.
How is it that the France are
undoubtedly in some sense insides view,
uh,
determined by their colonial interests
and the Germans who seems so much to
reflect a French attitudes
have no colonial interests,
at least in the Middle East.
Uh, and it's quite, you know,
sort of quite honestly tries to come to
terms with this. His answer is, well,
German, uh, orientalism is simply
derived in scholarly terms from French,
uh, or anilism. It has the
stamp of that thinking, uh,
and reflects that thinking.
And so there you are,
he could have said on the other hand,
however,
that a certain mindset toward
the third world, and this is,
and this is the point I've been
making about this particular issue,
dictates a certain way of structuring
one's thought about that world,
irrespective of whether or not there
are colonial interest involved.
And so that's, that's what I
mean by raising the question, uh,
is coloniality always at
issue in cases of this kind.
Finally, there's a kind of confusion, uh,
in thinking about these
things like confusion,
which is w which is a distilled in
the history of the British east India
company, which is both nationalists
and as it were globalizing,
but a confusion, uh, which comes
out more in more recent, uh,
the more recent history
of, um, of coloniality.
And that is, well, what
drives coloniality?
Is it always nationalism or as seems
increasingly the case in the modern world?
Is it trans national,
uh,
interests of glue in globalization?
Is it,
in other words,
is the relationship between the colonists
and the colonized a relation of ace of
some sort of metropolitan nation
with respect to a provincial empire?
Or is it a relation which is dictated and
generated by the economic interests of
globalization?
This is a complex subject,
which generates a great deal of debate in
the field, uh, that we take up today. Uh,
but, um, but in a way,
I mean, it's, it's, we,
we can't just say, well,
nationalism isn't important anymore.
Now it's globalization because actually,
um,
nationalism seems to have reappeared,
ah,
in the Bush foreign policy even possibly
to be continued in the Obama foreign
policy.
Uh,
and so there's a complex relationship
still between nationalism and
globalization, uh, that, uh, needs
to be considered and thought about.
If these, uh, social relations
are to be clearly understood.
And finally there is within
postcolonial studies,
especially among those, uh, who, uh,
represent,
uh,
the various are colonized
interest of the world.
There's the question to borrow an
expression from Gaietry speeback,
how should the subaltern speak?
And it has to do,
uh, most vividly with the very
question which language should the,
should the subaltern speak in Spi vacs?
Own question is,
can the subaltern speak at all?
Uh,
and Saeed raises that
question as you notice, uh,
during the course of his
analysis. Um, but the, but,
but the related issue is, okay,
suppose the subaltern can't speak, uh,
I suppose, um, in Googie
Wafi Django for example,
can write a novel what not,
what language should it be written in,
in Googie, uh, campaigned,
uh, in his more recent career,
um, not to write in English
and also to urge other,
uh, African writers to
write in a native languages,
uh, and not in the language
of the colonizer. Uh,
and this is a, and this is a,
uh, a frequently heard opinion,
um, from within postcolonial studies,
but debates worlds around it.
Because of course, the means
of circulation of literary, uh,
influence, uh, is, uh, languages that, uh,
draw upon, uh, international
publishing possibilities, uh,
and not languages, uh, that can
only be grasped and published.
And disseminated locally.
So there are two,
you have a complicated issue, uh, but uh,
or controversy on both sides
of which there's much to say.
But as I say for us today,
it's simply a question or more simply
a question because when you've got Homi
Bhabha on the syllabus, there's no such
thing as simplicity. So I should say, uh,
it's a question of following the
trajectory or development, uh,
between specifically between,
uh,
side and Baba and then beginning
to think about say aid.
I thought we wouldn't think about it.
And we'd think instead for a moment,
at least about once again about Virginia
Wolf and the second chapter of a room
of one's own, uh, this young woman,
Mary Beaten Mary seat and Mary Carmichael,
whoever she is,
it sitting in the British library.
Uh,
and she's thought that she'd
spend the morning trying to
figure out, um, what, uh,
scholars thought about women. You
know, after all, you know, this,
this is sort of where the
subject is women and fiction. Um,
I'm supposed to be addressing these
undergraduates on this subject.
What do I know about women? I had
better go to the library and find out.
So she expects to get, uh, you know,
to just to find a couple of books and
she'll be all set and instead she simply
overwhelmed and she,
and there's this avalanche of
material and she submits, you know,
maybe a dozen or two, uh, call slips, uh,
and then sits back waiting for the
material to appear. And of course,
the point of it is that everything
in the British library on the,
what turns out to be the voluminous
subject of women is written by Matt.
All right.
Everything and she begins to take note
of the way these things are described in
the, you know, sort of pre computer
database. Uh, that is to say,
how do you classify the various things
that men have to say about women.
And this is the way it goes.
Condition in Middle Ages of habits in the
Fiji Islands of worshiped as goddesses
by weaker in moral sense than idealism
of greater conscientiousness of South Sea
Islanders,
age of puberty,
among attractiveness of offered as
sacrifice to small size of brain,
of profounder,
subconsciousness of less
hair on the body of mental,
moral and physical inferiority of love,
of children of greater length,
of life,
of weaker muscles, of
strength, of affections,
of vanity,
of higher education,
of Shakespeare's opinion of Lord
Birkin heads, opinion of dean ends,
his opinion of library areas,
opinion of Dr Johnson's
opinion of Mr Oscar Browning's,
opinion of and.dot dot.
The list can continue.
In other words, she sits there,
she, she simply overwhelmed.
And what she of course is telling us is
that there's lots and lots and lots and
lots of opinions on record about women.
All of them expressed by men.
So now thinking about Edward Psyche,
if Edwards had taken up
Virginia Woolf's project,
if Edward aid had undertaken
to write a room of one's own,
the title of it would have
been female ism. Alright?
Because that's precisely
what he means by orientalism,
the vast body of information.
Some of it's scholarly,
some of it just sort of
sheerly doc's illogical.
The vast body of information about
people's called oriental by and large,
especially in the 19th century tradition,
uh,
Osi eads main concern is the
peoples of the Middle East. Uh,
and he shows how it is that there's a,
there's a certain reason why this is
an appropriate term to use for that
tradition of scholarship and philology
in the 19th century. In any case,
the vast body of material
published about these people.
And there are, and it's perfectly
true that there, there's the,
there are the infinitely long shelves
of the library devoted to multivolume
treatises on this topic.
All of them written by us in the West us,
you know about this other
who is perpetually in our
imaginary and constructed by
us in the variety of ways.
That side discusses a page 1811,
uh,
the right hand column. I'm sorry. Ah,
yes. The right hand column. He says
toward the bottom of the column,
orientalism is premised upon exteriority.
That is on the fact that the orientalist
poet or scholar makes the Orient Speak,
describes the orient renders his
mysteries playing for and to the West.
Just as in Wolf Man's opinions about
women getting themselves expressed in
books.
Make the subject of woman clear
to the an audience of men.
All right,
so
let me in bef before moving in with
some more depth and precision into sides
text.
Uh,
let me quickly explain what I mean by
saying that's I aid and Baba constitute a
kind of sequence.
I'm thinking in particular of Elaine Show
Walters distinction between feminists
and Gyno.
Critical criticism.
You remember the distinction which is
echoed by the way in gates, his essay,
the distinction is first you get criticism
in which the treatment of women in
literature by men is
the focus of attention.
And then subsequently
you get criticism in wet.
The women's tradition,
the voice of women
themselves is the focus. Uh,
and uh,
as Showalter believes the more
fruitful terrain for criticism.
So you can see that in that, that in
that context, in way of making it,
by way of making that distinction,
you can see that site is decidedly
phase one because of course,
or anilism is about the treatment of
the Middle Eastern other by the West.
Uh,
and so it is sort of,
it can be slotted in to that same moment,
but what's interest and then Homi Bhabha,
uh,
is obviously in a variety
of ways, uh, takes up, uh,
the subject position of the
colonized of the subaltern.
He doesn't leave out the subject
position of the, uh, of the colonizer,
uh, because he sees them as
being radically interrelated. Uh,
but he plainly is as interested in a
variety of ways of talking about the
traditions of the colonized as he
is of talking about the way in which
colonization takes place and
expresses itself. So in that sense,
we can see aid and Baba as
belonging to these two phases,
uh,
as mapped by show Walter.
And as I say also in passing by gates.
But actually,
and I'm sorry for the confusion
of this heading, actually,
there's another way in which side and
Baba can be understood as phase one and
phase two.
And that has much more to do with
the tradition of literary theory,
which in their ways both show Walter and
gates have rejected insisting that one
needs to commandeer white male
literary theory for one's own purposes.
I suppose it's a question how it does,
how this issue doesn't come
up inside eight and Baba,
it could perhaps be answered by saying
that precisely in the situation of
colonialism, uh, the intellectuals,
a third world colonized intellectuals,
nevertheless,
are educated, uh, in, uh,
high octane male,
uh,
metropolitan institutions by which of
course one means primarily Oxford and
Cambridge. Um, and so
in a certain sense, uh,
they come to identify,
um, and this is not a,
this is not actually a thing,
apart from Baba has argument
about, uh, about hybridity.
They come to identify in some measure
with the educational agenda of the
colonizer and participate in it.
Now that speculative,
it may simply be that we have missed out
on those moments when I'm [inaudible]
and Baba to maybe talking about the
way in which the white male traditional
literary theory needs to be appropriated.
But for the moment,
what I want to point out is this side's
are anilism works very much in the
historical moment of what
we call structure Elysium.
That is to say it's primary concern
is with the binary opposition,
a mutual and interdependent
binary opposition of central
self and decentralized
other, uh, including as
we'll see in a minute,
the way in which the construction of
the otherness of the other is actually
covertly. Also at the same
time, a means of constructing,
defining d limited than delimiting,
the nature of selfhood or in
this case of being western.
And so there's a fundamental by
binarism insights point of view,
which by the way has also been often
been criticized and it's been criticized,
uh,
most often from the standpoint
of Baba whom you can see.
Because if only because he's constantly
referring to dairy dies. Famous Essay,
the double session of which is about
Malheur, may, uh, about all. And,
and also because,
uh,
he appropriates a great deal of
the language and style of Derrida.
You can see that Baba takes with respect
to the binarism of structuralism,
a deconstructive attitude.
In other words,
his sense of these
relations breaks down into,
at the very least a redoubling sense
of what he calls double consciousness.
So that one can't clearly identify
colonizer and colonized as a binary
opposition.
It's more complicated than that.
And it's a series of issues that turns
on a highly Derridean sense of what one
might mean by difference.
And so all I'm out of say
is that the relations I eat,
Baba is phase one,
phase two in that regard as well.
And by the way,
this is a tendency that one can find in
other forms of litter of theory having
to do with identity.
The relationship between the classical
feminism that we have been discussing so
far and the gender theory that we
will be discussing on Tuesday is one,
especially in the case of
Julio Butler is once again, uh,
a relation that could be understood as
between structuralism and deconstruction.
So, um, so, so there too,
you have a not completely overlapping but
from the standpoint of our concerns in
literary theory,
nevertheless rather interesting a way in
which this succession [inaudible] Baba
is phase one, phase two in two
different ways, uh, that can be,
uh, identified I think
usefully. All right,
so that then about their relationship.
So what,
what about site? How do
we, how do we get at, um,
the issues that side wants to talk about,
um,
and understand the way in which
he thinks they have integrity. Um,
before I think I'd like actually to begin
with a word or two about truth because
side,
uh,
makes it clear that in a way,
the demonization of orientalism that
his project undertakes isn't really
undertaken because orientalism
is necessarily a pack of lies.
He's, he, maybe he waffled
a little bit about this,
but it's not really ultimately the
point for him whether or anilism lies or
tells the truth.
This is,
this is the way he puts it on page
1802 in the right hand column,
a third qualification,
one ought never to assume that
the structure of orientalism
is nothing more than
a structure of lies or myths,
which were the truth about them
to be told would simply blow away.
I myself believe that orientalism is
more particularly valuable as a sign of
European Atlantic power over the orient
than it is as a verb Riddick discourse
about the RN. Uh, nevertheless,
what we must respect and try to grasp is
the sheer knitted together strength of
orientalist discourse. In
other words, you know, I mean,
so one of Napoleon's adjutants during
Napoleon's campaign through Egypt wrote a
10 volume east wide leg reaped.
Many of the texts whom to whom Cy
aid mansions in passing in his,
uh, in his introduction to
orientalism are just as long.
I mean you've got 50 volume,
sort of a gigantic scholarly
undertakings and you've got to admit,
well, you know, if they're saying that
much, there's gotta be something in it.
That's true. Um, there is after
all a great deal of knowledge, uh,
of a certain kind, at least that
has gone into thinking of this kind.
And so one can't just say,
my point is that none of it's true.
And so he'd, uh, is at pains to
make a distinction therefore,
between truth and value.
It's not that, um,
orientalist discourse is
necessarily true or false.
It is the case though that it is
insidiously d valuing of its object of
attention that there is an
implicit Eurocentrism which
side does go so far as to
consider a form of racism
in our animalism quiet,
irrespective of any measure or degree
of truth that what are after all the
meticulous researches have a lot
of these characters turn up. Uh,
for example, on page 18, 12, uh,
the lefthand column,
he says,
my analysis of the orientalist
text therefore places emphasis.
This is about a third of the way down,
which is by no means invisible for
such representative on the evidence,
which is by no means invisible for such
representations as representations not
as natural descriptions of the Orient.
Now we might pause for amendment minute
over that as a possible object of
critique,
uh,
yet because at the end of his essay or
at the end of the introduction as you
have it, uh, you notice side saying, look,
I don't take up here the question of
how one might actually write correctly
about, you know, about these people.
He doesn't take up, for example,
the question of what it might
be like to be, um, uh, uh,
sort of a representative
of these minorities,
uh, or colonized figures
and to write about oneself.
He doesn't really take up the question
whether the bias of somebody else writing
about me.
You know,
a man writing about a woman is
worse than the bias of my own pride,
preconceptions and
prejudices about myself.
He admits that he doesn't really have,
and advanced theory that's a cure is
one kind of representation as true or
authentic and secure is.
And other kind of
representation as biased, uh,
and inauthentic. He says, another
scholar will perhaps take this up.
I leave it alone in my book
and it is left alone. Uh,
the problem being that the claim
remains that that he, that he does,
um, uh, anticipating, uh,
many other people who have
written on this subject,
he does impugn orientalism as mere
representation at is to say as not,
uh,
as the opposite because it is a
representation the opposite of a natural
evocation of an ethos or world.
Um,
so we just do want to put a little
question mark in the margin then say there
and say, well, fine, fine. Granted,
this is all representation. Uh,
where is the text? Where could
the text be that would be natural?
Is there,
for example,
any such thing as we've asked ourselves
over the course of this semester as a
natural sign,
the sign being arbitrary,
it does place us already pretty
securely in the realm of representation.
All right? All of these
questions then posed a buy sides,
a sense of the relationship between
truth and value in the history of
orientalist scholarship. Now,
where is he coming from? Uh,
he's quite open about it. Uh, and um,
and it's perhaps worth pausing over.
And I over an idea common to the two
scholar theorists who matter most to him.
Michel Foucault and the Italian
Marxist on Antonio Gramsci.
Uh, first of all, uh, just uh,
to pass and review, uh, his,
the way in which he's indebted
to ground g on page 1803,
the lefthand column
sites as culture of course is to be found
operating within civil society where
the influence of ideas of institutions
and of other persons works not through
domination,
but by what Graham she calls consent.
That was,
it's not just a question of having
forced down your throat certain ideas or
concepts or laws for that matter,
but a circulation of knowledge.
So called of feeling
about things of ideology,
which through consent
establishes certain attitudes,
uh, uh, of bias. And
so this is what Graham,
she,
the distinction that grime she makes
between the way in which one is imposed on
by actual power and authority and the
way in which one is imposed on by the
circuit by the circulations of what
we've been exposed to in the past,
uh,
as being called ideology seems
so to continue in any society,
not totalitarian says Sa Ead,
certain cultural forms predominate over
others just as certain ideas are more
influential than others.
The form of this cultural leadership
is what Graham she has identified as
hegemony and this is the ta and this
is a term that you will frequently and
counter particularly in Marxist criticism,
but it is also a term very closely related
to what for most western readers is
more famous in the work
of Michel Foucault,
the term power or sometimes
power slash knowledge.
As you will learn in the excerpt from
Foodco that you'll be reading on Tuesday,
Fuko light grumpshe sheet
makes a distinction between
power merely as that which
is exercised by the police or by the
legal arm of society or by the dictator or
by the government.
And power as the ways,
the frequently insidious ways in which
knowledge is circulated and made hedge.
I'm on it.
That is to say made
authoritative and Fuko is,
pat is fascinated by the structure of
this circulation of knowledge that is in
fact the essential subject
matter of all of his late work,
the way in which we are thinking that
we are sort of free contemplative agents
in the world.
In fact,
browbeaten by structures of opinion
circulating around us that low us into
feeling that we're in the
presence of the truth.
Whereas of course we're
only in the presence of one
form or another of motivated
bias.
Uh,
so both grumpshe and Fuko make the
distinction between absolute power.
And as Graham,
she calls it hegemony.
And as Fuko calls it power knowledge,
Saeed is talking here
about power knowledge.
He's not talking about the imposition of
law through force or any other means on
a colonized world.
He's talking about the way in which
opinions construct that world and
simultaneously reinforce the authority
of those who generate the opinions he
does.
However,
and I think it's important to point
this relatively subtle distinction. Oh,
he does, however, disagree. Um,
from Fuko in one respect. On page 18, 13,
he goes back to what we
already know about food co,
which is who co's interested interest
in the author function as opposed to the
author authors generally speaking,
Fuko wants to say,
or not authorities,
uh,
but simply but simply
vessels of forms of opinion,
certain authors who come very close to
being an authority we call founders of
discursivity, but even in their cases,
it's the nature of the discourse. Uh,
and not their existence as authors,
which is important.
Side wants to say,
I take authors a little bit more seriously
than that and he does on page 1813 in
the right hand column where he says
food Coby leaves that in general,
the individual texts or author
counts for very little empirically.
That is to say through my experience
empirically in the case of orientalism and
perhaps nowhere else I find this
not to be. So, in other words,
the authors,
the central philologists and,
and social historians and explorers
and demographers who have written so
extensively on this part of
the world are authorities.
They are the oracles
from which generalized,
uh, and ultimately commonplace
opinions disseminate, uh,
as power knowledge.
And it's not a question,
therefore a kind of silent drumbeat of
opinion expressing itself over and over
again, which is more what
interests Fuko. So, uh,
so site as I say, uh, distinguishes
himself, uh, subtly, uh,
from Foodco in that regard.
Well, nevertheless, uh,
confessing openly,
uh,
the influence both of food co and
grumpshe fee on his way of approaching his
material.
So the circulation a of power, uh, as,
as a circulation of power.
I should say the effect of orientalism
is something that ultimately concerns
Saeed.
Well,
he says the somewhat rhetorically because
he obviously does concern if that it
has an effect on the peoples in question.
But what ultimately concerns side is
the effect of orientalism on the Euro
centric mind.
Indeed,
the degree to which it even can be said
to construct the euro centric mind.
Page 1806,
the right hand column.
My real argument is that orientalism
is and does not simply represent a
considerable dimension of modern
political intellectual culture.
And as such,
has less to do with the orient
than it does with our world.
Now here you can see the degree to which
side is saying something very similar
to what Tony Morrison said in her essay.
The existence of black as
absence needs to be understood.
For example,
if we're studying the history of
American literature as the means of
constructing whiteness,
of the,
of that which liberates whiteness from
the forms of constraints under which it's
been chafing at the beat at the bit.
And Morrison of course,
develops this argument
beautifully and she, uh,
quite clearly takes it from the Fourth
Chapter of Hegel's phenomenology of mind,
uh,
as a way of understanding
the master slave dialectic.
In other words, in Hagle, uh,
it's clear, uh, as Hagle, uh,
develops the idea that master and slave
are absolutely necessary to each other
in a structure of mutuality.
The master isn't,
the master can't define himself as free
or a superior without the existence of
the slave.
The trickiness that the slave learns.
Being in this position of subordination
involving the development of all sorts
of complicated skills means
ultimately that the slave, uh,
becomes as it were,
that which drives the
master technologically and
ultimately controls the master,
uh, in a kind of, uh,
a fable of class reversal,
uh, which is, uh,
which continues to reverse itself again
and again and again on various grounds.
Um, this is, uh, the fable, uh,
the or w which at the same time is a
philosophy of class relations that we find
that that structure's Morrison's
argument, uh, and which I think also, uh,
also structures sides.
And I want to make the transition to Baba,
um,
because obviously this is a
form of binarism, uh, the, the,
uh,
the two signifiers in relation to each
other need each other in the way that we
described when we were discussing.
So Sir and structuralism,
I said,
I can't simply say that our
red light has positive value.
You remember the whole argument?
I have to see, uh, the red,
the red light in the context of the
semiotics system to which it belongs.
I have to see it as being different from
or opposed to something else in order
to grasp it. I cannot know it
positively. In other words,
I can only know it negatively.
This basic concept of
structuralism in the,
so Syria and tradition is what creates
is what shapes binary arguments of the
kind that one finds in [inaudible].
We know ourselves negatively
as the not other is.
The bet is, is, is the basic
principle, the theoretical principle,
which under which underlies,
uh, obviously, uh,
aspect of the argument which are also
as a side says empirical. I mean, yeah,
I can say it's a structuralist idea,
but I really believe it because
I've seen it in operation.
It's not just structure, it was him.
In other words, it shares, however,
with structuralism, uh, a,
a theoretical predisposition and Baba,
if you look at page 18,
79 openly criticizes the premise
of binarism of this kind,
not just anybody binarism but he
actually does go directly back to Hagle.
In other words,
he identifies the source of thinking
of this kind bottom of 1879 right hand
column when he says it is this ambivalence
that makes the boundaries of colonial
positionality,
the division of self,
other the question of colonial power,
the differentiation of colonizer,
colonized,
different from both the Hungarian
master slave dialectic or,
and he goes on to mention other things,
but I just want to focus on this
as a moment in which Baba is,
uh, is, is, is,
is distinguishing himself as clearly
as he can from the project of Saeed.
Alright, now this, the passage I just
read begins with the word ambivalence.
What does Baba mean by ambivalence?
Let's try to start there and
see if we can work our way into.
Bob has complex thinking on these matters.
Uh,
first by way of the notion of ambivalence.
Well,
and I'm going to put this in terms
of an historical example. Uh, I,
because I hope that will
make it a little clearer.
There is the ambivalence of the
colonizer toward the colonized.
In other words, it's not just one
mindset that drives colonization.
In the historical experience
of England in the east,
in the east India company,
there are two distinct phases,
phases which actually repeat themselves
recurrently even throughout the 20th
century.
The first in the 18th century is the
period of the government of the east India
Company by Warren Hastings,
who in a certain sense was interested
in what we call going native and also
encouraged,
uh,
all of his provincial administrators to
do likewise Hastings and other words,
insight in terms knew a great
deal about the or analyzed other.
He knew all the local
languages and dialects.
He knew all the customs he knew, he
really knew everything there was to know.
Uh,
and in a certain sense was a person who
did go native while at the same time,
uh, wielding an iron with
an iron grip of authority,
power over the colonized other,
his ambivalence,
it himself then embodies a
certain ambivalence in not
giving an edge as to the
actual control of authority,
while at the same time seeming
to become one with the other.
But then there's the
historical ambivalence,
which expresses itself in a completely
different attitude and attitude,
which surfaced in the east India company.
Early in the 19th century,
uh, under the, uh, under the
supervisor ship of Charles Grant.
Now, Charles Grant, uh, was, uh,
as a d there had been a tremendous
revival of fundamentalist religion,
mainly methodism in England.
Uh,
and this and this evangelical enthusiasm
spread itself into the interest of the
empire.
And so Charles Grant and others like him,
no had no longer had any interest
at all and going native, uh,
but on the other, but,
but on the contrary,
insisted that a standard of
Englishness and in the staff,
the standard of the English Bible,
the coming of the English book that
Bhabha talks about at the beginning of his
essay be firmly implanted,
and that the imposition of Englishness
on the colonized other be the agenda of
colonization. The famous
historian, Thomas Babington,
Macaulay, uh, codified this attitude, uh,
in Wa in a famous document he wrote,
and it'd be assumed to be infamous
document called the minute on education,
uh,
which insisted that the
education of the Indian peoples,
uh, in the, uh,
under the regime of the east
India company B be conducted,
can strictly according to English models
that missionaries no longer try to
adapt their ideas to local
customs, uh, and folkways,
but that everything be strictly
anglicised. So this is a completely,
completely different attitude toward
colonization and it can be understood as a
sort of historical ambivalence.
Um, I'd actually, I,
I'd actually like to pause over an
example of what you might call the Warren
Hastings moment. Um, uh, vicious example,
although an absolutely fascinating one
in the disturbing masterpiece by John
Ford called the searchers. I hope some
of you at least know that film. Uh,
the John Wayne Character,
uh, is a, uh, kind of,
um,
so lone stranger anticipate,
which is of course not infrequent
in the western, um, who, uh,
shows up at the house of some relatives.
And here's that w that a daughter has
been abducted by the native Americans,
by the Indians.
Now,
the thing about John Wayne is
that he's a vicious in this film,
is that he's a vicious racist.
That he absolutely hates the Indians,
but he is not a vicious racist
from the standpoint of ignorance.
He is in fact a person who is,
has an himself in a certain sense,
gone native. He knows all the
Indian languages and dialects.
He knows all their customs. He has, uh,
he has throughout a lifetime,
made a careful study of the
people he hates. And this is a,
and this is a volatile mixture to be
exposed to in a film because we're a much
more comfortable with the idea that
hatred arises out of ignorance. All right?
And the, and, and what is
so deeply disturbing about,
about John Ford's,
the searchers as that is,
it is a portrait of
absolutely vicious racism. Uh,
which is, which again, you
know, so he'd says, hey,
it's not necessarily truth, but we
do have to acknowledge, you know,
a certain local, thick
description we have. We have,
we have to acknowledge that there's a,
that there's quite a bit of information
at this person's disposal. Um,
and all of that is born out in the,
uh,
characterization of John Wayne in this
film or in Hastings was a lot like that.
Warren Hastings knew everything about
people whom he ultimately didn't really
respect and whom he insisted on a
ruling with the Iron Fist of authority.
Uh,
and that's the kind of thing that's the
Baba is thinking about when he thinks
about the ambivalence of the colonizer,
the relationship between knowledge and
value as it's already been enunciated
inside,
but also the fact that there's more
than one mindset for the colonizer.
There's the local knowledge
mindset and there's,
and there is the sort of raising the
absolute unequivocal standard of the
colonizing, uh, uh, uh,
of, of the colonizer, uh,
that these are two different attitudes,
each of which dictate
different strategies,
particularly strategies of education.
So that's ambivalence,
uh,
the ambivalence of the colonizer.
Then there's the ambivalence
of the colonized. Um,
and that too has to be,
uh,
understood as a complex
relation to cooptation.
The anecdote with w with which Baba
begins, I think is fascinating,
uh, and well worth
attending to. You have, um,
not a colonizer, but someone
thoroughly co-opted, uh,
an evangelical, a converted Christian, uh,
of Indian descent. Um, who is,
who represents in a way that the people
he finds sitting under the tree root
trees,
reading the Bible considered to be
completely authentic because he believes,
uh, and is perfectly happy to believe
that the Bible and for that matter and for
that matter of Christianity
itself is an English gift.
But he's met with the response of
people who resist that, who say,
you know, this is very
interesting stuff. You know,
we wish we could have some
local authority for it.
Our understanding as we got this, this
book, this book directly from God,
that's our understanding and we
have our own attitude toward it.
Sure they will get baptized one of
these days. But in the meantime,
we got to go home and take care of
the harvest. So, you know, W we,
we'll get around to that.
Don't worry about it. And by
the way, if we get baptized,
we certainly can't take the Eucharist,
uh, because you know, that's,
that's eating meat. We don't eat
meat. You know, we are who we are.
And so that,
and,
and you can see that these cunningly
in situ insinuated provisos,
uh, to the attitude that, um, that the,
the missionary wants to inculcate in
them in a very real way completely
undermines his purpose. They don't
think of it as the English Bible.
They won't accept it as the English Bible.
They will only accept it as an authority
that's mediated by their own values,
which transforms the document.
I mean,
you can see it again as this
is 18, 13, as Bob points out,
this was precisely at the
moment when we're moving,
when the regime of authority is moving
from the Warren Hastings Paradigm to the
Charles Grant Paradigm.
And it's no longer possible to think
in terms of adapting the Bible to local
beliefs and circumstances.
And so this is a moment in
which the complexity of the
attitude of the colonized
is brought up as the attitude
of the suborned missionary.
And there's the more complicated and
interesting attitude of the people he
encounters sitting under
these trees. Um, the, uh,
at page 1886,
the right hand column,
that's actually not the
passage I wanted to read.
A page 1881 on the left hand column.
This is a very difficult passage.
Everything in Baba is
difficult. Um, I want to,
I think I want to gloss it by a suggestion
to you that what he's talking about
is that the ambivalence which,
and,
and we might as well say right
out that this ad ambivalence is,
he has a term for,
and it's hybridity is the
double consciousness of
the cow colonized hovering
between submission.
That is to say submission to authority,
but with a difference submission
to authority on one's own terms.
And on the other hand,
acquiescence acquiescence
in authority as given,
which of course is basically the position
of the missionary. And with that said,
uh, I'll read the passage in which, uh,
Baba describes this hybridity in the
double consciousness of the colonize,
the place of difference and otherness
or the space of the adversarial within
such a system of disposal.
As I've proposed is never entirely on
the outside or implacably oppositional,
not just in other words,
again as a question of us versus them.
It is a pressure and a presence that
acts constantly if unevenly along the
entire boundary of authorization,
which is also authority that is on the
surface between what I've called disposal
as be stole at.
I take that meaning submission.
You simply,
okay fine,
I give in and disposition as inclination,
which is, Hey, I kinda like
that. I go along with it. Uh,
I given spontaneously now to give in a
simply as a form of recognizing one's
beaten,
you know,
as a form of submission is puts one
and the position of what Baba calls sly
civility. And this is the position, uh,
that I'd like to go back to for a moment
as being very closely related to what
gates calls signifying.
A Baba gives a number of examples
of this slide civility, uh,
in his texts.
But of course,
it's all present in the clever and
wonderfully rich ironies of these figures
sitting under the trees
in his opening anecdote.
But let me just give you an example
of how sly civility works as a form of
signifying and as a stats
of colonized resistance,
a recuperation of the will
perhaps in a postmodern sense,
which is nevertheless not rebellious,
not in any way,
um,
and visioning and overthrow of authority,
but is a means of living in
the framework of authority.
Just a quick example and then I'll let
you go to African American people are
having a conversation and the presence
of a white person and they cheerfully
and, and, and, and with,
you know, with, with,
with broad smiles on their face referred
to this person in his presence as bill.
Now, Bill is a derisive and
derogatory term for white people.
Uh,
and as the white person standing there
has two choices in response to hearing
himself referred to as bill.
He can either take umbrage and say,
Oh, why are you saying that about me?
I'm a nice guy. You don't, you,
you know how to say that. Uh,
in which case the needling
effect of the term,
um,
has taken hold.
Or he can play the fool and pretend
that he doesn't know that he's being
signified on, uh, and pretend that well,
it's perfectly okay to be called bill.
And either way,
you see it's a win win situation.
They, uh, the, the, this, you know,
this is this, this guy bill is
the slave owner, right? You know,
he likes to get along with people.
Uh,
so he's sitting around having this
conversation and he hears them calling him
bill. Alright? So because he's, he,
because there's an element of good
nature in his slave owning personality,
he's stuck.
He can either complain that
people are treating him unfairly,
which of course is neither here
nor there in terms of the power,
in terms of the structure
of power involved.
Or he can play the fool and pretend that
he doesn't even notice that he's being
made fun of. Uh, and so either way,
this is an example of that sly civility,
which signifies on the man and which
makes it clear that while the structure of
power can't be overthrown anytime soon,
there are nevertheless is
a way of living at least a,
of keeping one sense of humor within
the existing structure of power,
uh, while giving the man a hard time. Uh,
that is the attitude,
the set of attitudes that
Baba is articulating in his
notion of the hybridity of
the colonized, uh, which
takes the form in performance.
We're going to have a lot more to
say about performance on Tuesday,
which takes in the form,
takes the form in performance
of this sly civility.
I think it's page 1889 that
he gives us that expression,
which I think you should keep hold of.
Which I would compare very closely with
what Henry Louis Gates calls signifying.
Okay.
See you on Tuesday.